everybody my name is Danielle Olson and
I'm a fourth year PhD candidate at the
MIT computer science and artificial
intelligence laboratory I also work as a
research assistant for the MIT Center
for transfer to the Fox row today it's
my pleasure to be joined by cream van
Khalifa for MIT cast three questions
series
all right so I would love for you to
just give an introduction to the
audience of who you are and where where
your work has taken you so I am in
bowling my name is kevin kelly fat this
is my base here and i've been war
correspondents for 15 18 years depending
on how you you see that at the ends and
i've done a project called the enemy
which started developing when I was at
the open doc lab at MIT and then worked
with Professor for Fox Harrell and cast
to develop that further that became a
full-blown experience after
[Music]
really
[Music]
the enemy was born out of my frustration
as a photojournalist and more
correspondent for almost 20 years I have
photograph conflicts and witnessed the
consequences of huge geopolitical shifts
when I became a father I simply knew I
could not keep working on the front
lines yet I was not done trying to
understand wars
[Music]
never woken up on a new walk
[Music]
my friends in Israel when they know I'm
heading for Gaza come help themselves
but to wish me luck interests they safe
they believe a lot of people in Gaza I
irrational also when I spent weeks
working in Gaza and I'm about to return
to Israel my Palestinian friends are
telling me the exact same thing be
careful there
[Music]
the project is rooted in my experience
as a war photographer going from one
side of the frontline to the other and
finding that the fighters dreams hopes
and nightmares often more similar than
they are different so there is a bigger
story than the war itself and this is
the one I want to explore and share for
the enemy I am using the latest
technologies in virtual and augmented
reality so you can engage directly with
the combatants and meet them hear them
and feel them the way I did in many part
of our walls you create an enemy as a
kid without having met your enemy
because the society around you has
created an enemy in the other so the
question is could I be you if I was on
the other side
[Music]
wonderful
so I guess to start the conversation I
would love to just ask you what brought
you to MIT and how did your experience
collaborating with Professor Fox Carell
in the MIT community impact your work
well I was invited to add my tea by
William Enrico and Sarah Wilson at the
open rock lab so this is that was my
first introduction and and then from
there everything to kind of sense even
though no looking back it's it's it's a
I can see I could see how it transformed
but it's been I think the first thing is
the most important thing for me has been
the ability to break all the walls that
I had constructed around my work and how
I was looking at storytelling and and
being in an environment where everything
is challenged whatever is the status quo
is challenged help me challenge my own
journalism and then with this using new
technologies but most importantly new
technologies are there and to keep
evolving but what was I guess the
richest part of all was my collaboration
with Professor Fox Harrell and in that
sense that as a journalist and him as a
scientist we have different sets of
ethics and it was so interesting to
share those and see her silence works
and how journalists works and what we
can do on one side while we can't and in
finding a bridge in between in order to
do something that had not been done so
far and this had phony change to work my
ability to really push the boundaries
further and and then learn a great deal
on on the process
it's been about I think six or seven
years since we first met through Fox's
advance identity representation course
and I remember just being struck by the
lineage of the enemy project from it
being for today a photo exhibit all the
way to becoming a virtual reality
exhibition and an AR app could you share
a little bit about you know you said
something along the lines of stories or
how we make sense of the world and
experiences it's how our how we remember
them could you share how these different
media forms have influenced how you've
told this story over time it's in a lot
of way when you're photojournalist and
you do for a story you already have a
distribution in place you work for
magazines the magazine have their own
distribution it's a lot you don't need
to think about and as a war
correspondent you you really try to
concentrate on the story you're doing
knowing you have the magazines behind
you but as you evolve and as you start
thinking differently about your own work
it is always important to put to use the
best medium in in for the best audience
and so in that sense when I was medium
base for a long time I am NOT medium
based anymore and I think the big
transformation is there and the way I'm
thinking is what is what is the issue
that I want to cover that I think needs
to be put in light and then once I've
got the issue
I wonder who should listen to that issue
in order to have an impact who are the
best audiences that should be confronted
to this and sometimes the mighty the
local people and sometimes there might
be you know stakeholders and and those a
different strategy in order to get to
one place or the other one and so I
think in that sense thinking that what
is my project who's my audience and then
finally what is the best medium to reach
that audience so if you it completely
transformed my way of thinking about my
own work in that sense that my audience
comes first I'm already in centered now
and then the medium comes only after
finding what is the best medium for that
audiences that's a great segue to my
next question for you in talking about
the audience and how they received your
work on so my next question is can you
tell us a little bit about the impact of
the enemy virtual reality
addition and the augmented reality app
and more specifically maybe if you could
share some of this feedback you've
received from those who have experienced
the enemy yeah I mean you talked about
the experience before I wasn't aware I
was doing an experience VR was creating
the experience I wasn't creating the
Express I was just filling up the blocks
inside and in medium in itself this is
way more experimental so in that sense
it is always very important to to kind
of focus on what what is that that you
want to say and how you you you want to
put it through and having different
experience in different places with
different audiences is always really so
when it comes to the impact
I certainly least I've never been asked
to have an impact as a human being I've
wanted to have one and so this is a
markers that I've good up there and
trying to in trying to do it because
it's becoming
experiencial because the work has become
through VR and through walking in 300
meters square and meeting the people and
then having the choice to work in
different places and it's not a VR with
with a joystick in that sense it's
really you physically moving I think
this is what creates the experience and
the experience is what eventually
creates the impact how to I mean the
feedbacks I had for my audience we're
always more this is an experience they
remember it in the spoke about it as an
experience as a meeting they had with
fighters while if they didn't really had
those many but everything that was in
place here within the work was
simulating that meeting and I think it
creates when you have your own choice
when you can navigate left right listen
to the people they look at you directly
in the eye it creates a different level
of experience and then therefore a
different different kind of impact and
impact is different thing for different
people
I think in in in when you cover wars and
enemies the way I do the ultimate impact
would be to stop that war but that's a
bit too ambitious
I would call my work being much more of
a journalistic intervention journalism
is something that needs to bring you an
information that you didn't had in order
to make a better decision
but when you I mean I call it an
intervention because people go 50
minutes into this VR experience and
within the 50 minutes they almost forgot
they are in VR so once they reach back
life as they knew it before they've been
charged with this they've been charged
with the experience and and I think it
does change the sense of the perspective
it's a seeds that you put but it's hard
to tell if that C is gonna bring the the
largest and highest hope tree you've
seen in your life or if you just stay
there and never really spoke so in that
sense it's hard to really elsewhere but
this said we've done a few interviews
with users and specially in Tel Aviv
where we could show you know perhaps
what one of the user had to say about
the enemy walking on of this man moody
killed over the nicola foti
stem securely behind by line telephone
hoh-hoh
the monkeys would say commercial
establishments professional this battle
will eventually seen you come on no
challenge at all but they are mushroom
you shall have kilos it of hymns you can
connect it that way oh yeah give you a
whole kilo just like um the guitar which
is the robe and I'm also their moms
Archie dumb gangster don't cover this
the mothers aplomb with malaria huh
really small talk they're almost
uncovered what Sava do you see this is
really what I'm talking about the seeds
walking out of this it was really
surprised to have encounter his enemy
and to see similarities with his enemy
in order to kill uniquely dehumanize and
my work was really about real human
izing and trying to realize the other
and finding not not working on the
differences but what is similar in
between them and the basic humanity yes
you face killers yes if his people
who've been involved in very violent
but at the center they still have always
some hearts and some somewhere some
humanity and if you want to make peace
you need to reconcile with the humanity
in your enemy to start with and then fix
everything then after so I think that's
the first step we can see as a matter of
fact is he's an Israeli who's going to
be drafted and and go a few months later
in the army so this was an intervention
because he realized something about his
enemy you wouldn't have realized
otherwise thank you so much for sharing
that on that same thread of planting
seeds and watching them grow within your
audiences I'd love to know what projects
are you currently we're looking forward
to working on that so let's back up just
a second it was not long ago
what is the story I want to do who's the
audience I want to engage with and what
is the best medium to reach them so I
had gone to Congo and in 2015 for the
enemy I went to see the mines and I went
to see a mind very goldmine where people
were scratching was their hands the
world it's really a part of the hill was
tear apart and and I photographed the
photograph was my iPhone and suddenly it
struck me that I was using the minerals
they were mining and it was in my phone
and I was using them to photograph them
so I started thinking I need to do
something about that it's an old story
we know in within our electronics we
have so many rare earths minerals and
they come from countries that sometimes
are problematic and the DRC is
definitely problematic and so I'm trying
to create a link in between what's
happening in Congo and you having a
phone in your hands and I'm using
augmented reality you're going to be
able to visit all the parts and the
components of your phone and see where
those minerals are exactly located in
your phone and why are we using them
indefinitely why they're indispensable
and then from there we're going to be
trickling down to back to the to the
mind where we realize what is the
reality on the ground for the miners
that are working there
and dying in this condition human rights
abuse workers abuse if not armed groups
taking over some part in some minds and
in financing their own fights with with
with their the benefit of the might yeah
as somebody who works in computer
science you know I'm struck by how much
ethics have come into the conversation
and research circles and industry
circles but I think taking a step back
and being really critical about the
tools with which we tackle these issues
is incredibly powerful so I look forward
to seeing that work yeah it's it's
really trying to welcome younger
generation that are using those natively
those those electronics and then
reminding them there is people that are
mining those minerals and it doesn't
have to be that bloody it doesn't have
to carry so much injustice I'm looking
at my phone as something that enables
injustice it's not the way we look at
our phone instead the way we want to
look at our electronics but they do as
of today and us as consumer can request
to stop this we have the right to not
have blood in our phones and we should
in that sense this is where my work is
going and this is what I'm gonna be
proposing the audience within the work
is to also have a sense of range of
senses I don't like that and I want to
do something and would propose them to
do something in fact thank you so much
cream for taking the time to talk to our
community today
I'd love to pass the back to Katherine
long to close the series and I
appreciate everyone who joined us on
this webinar today Thank You Danielle
Thank You Corinne this was a great
conversation thanks to everyone who
joined us online audience please join us
next week for three questions with Jay
shy and beyond Flynn and visit art stop
mit.edu from anywhere for wide range of
arts activities online exhibitions
performances research and more have a
great weekend everyone thank you very
much see you from Berlin thank you